picked up now by Hegel back to the line radish
loads and fires a seed right on and monos got
that there was no whistle what happened there the
I was pulled everybody was cool Montreal plays the
puck it's in the back of the net it caught us off
guard it caught Zappa off guard kage has the goal
and it's two nothing that's a late Christmas gift
here's a look so mono everyone's gone to the bench
no whistle went kovich right to the back of the
net and he could have iced that puck wow I have
never seen that before holy M wow I mean I've
never seen that yeah I i' I've got no problem
inting I was fooled I thought that was a sto play
I stopped looking too I stopped looking at the ice
Brian remember when you played novice hockey and
your coach always told you to go stop in front of
the net so that they blow the whistle we assumed
it was squeezed and the whistle had blown but the
reaction of the Montreal Canadians and kovich
proves otherwise as he buries it into the open
net well this is the strangest thing I think I've
ever seen I've never see this one and there's no
humor there right now for that guy you never know
what you're going to see that one is for sure a
first you know I thought the goal he scoring on
us a few weeks ago was odd but this one for sure
takes the CI he'll put it behind the net One Touch
back door scar wheeler what a play by Ma Zan you
cannot one touch a pass prettier than that watch
this play by Savanah Jad behind the net and Blake
wheeler loves it is fifth as a ranger the long
time Winnipeg jet Captain gives the Rangers a
one- nothing lead the boards one time Manson safe
B rovski pck is free score popped out of the back
of the n one right over Bob rsk's head bosski
steps on his diick as he falls backward there's
the blocker save by B Roi steps on his stick falls
on his keer and Logan oconor I think he's going to
get credit for that goal EAD and Thomas behind the
play we're going at it as the catch shoot it and
they score it hit the glass and it bounced in now
the blues are objecting they're saying this is no
goal that it caught something in the panther bench
first it just hit the glass it hit the round part
of the glass if you stop it right here there's a
round partition here to protect the players and
it just took a really funny yeah that's good goal
right in the goal they feel like they're pretty
sure when they send it down to the coach saying I
think you should challenge this Michelle carmier
and Ryan Daisy these two guys are figuring it out
up the stands the the referees in the stands think
it's offside we'll see what the NHL Situation Room
says after the coach's challenge it was determined
that the play was on side therefore we have a goal
pass deflected by krier which threw the angle up
up and it popped over the top of the net and off
of Sorrow a magical bounce for the Flyers how did
that happen you could see the smile on Frost's
face it's like oh my gosh I can't believe that
you couldn't do that again if you tried a million
times off of krier and then off of the skate so
Morgan Frost the beneficiary of an early Christmas
giing was signal then waved off yeah terasa just
too aggressive now flurry racing to get back into
the net he Dives across the crease and the shot by
Dan forth went over the top of the goal Hartman as
flurry races to the bench a third time Johansson
on the back end he scores he's in he's out he's
in he's out mark on R doesn't know what to do
he's trying to get out of the net he's trying to
get back into the net a battler push through it
to beat Benson into that puck look out a turnover
and darene scores Jaret starting to make his way
to the bench Penguins lost possession and Rasmus
Dalene capitalizes Buffalo 3-1 jar as he just left
look at him look he looked right there and he
goes okay I'll take a shot look at jari trying
to get back just trying to stretch out buries it
right into the empty net long shot from the point
deflected on goal and Marr takes that off the
knet I think he did it on purpose y went full
Ronaldo with the header that might have bounced
off Anderson stick right in front of the Flames
go tender I think you're right make a pretty good
save loer sto Corpus Salo pressure not going away
oh look at that fo pass and Docker with a glove
save we've seen the lacrosse goal that was a
lacrosse pass and a little lacrosse play Popp it
out in front and Bernard dacker says I'll grab
that thank you very much racing forward forsberg
forsberg will get there forsberg hit the post oh
my laundry for could have put it away loose in
the trapezoid fought four bounces in they score
they tied it cig Smith with 13 seconds left Dallas
has come back everyone Still Standing but they're
stunned and we're headed to overtime it appears
steel cuts it off in the slot knocked down here's
a chance score dallis two seconds left can you
believe it it's a prec Christmas miracle the stars
have turned it around and they're going to win
this game 3 to2 unbelievable that guy's face says
all right there that this building is in shock
the stars were 133 seconds away from a regular
ation loss they double down with a onew hay maker
seen everybody trying and get into this H Sten and
N steps up doesn't go outside his crease oh the
games that players play we see some of that with
sha ay and Marty bror you get it that time oh it's
the what a nice byar wow what a glove save that
is why you wear the glove right oh my goodness
welcome back to LA where Tyler berzi is leading
the charge for the map Leafs and he's playing
with his usual Reckless abandon in the process
he managed to damage his beautiful tape jump so he
had to put a fix on it in classic puszi fashion he
gets the roll started with his teeth he gets only
the most delicate strip to fix I honestly have no
idea what he's fixing I'm sure there is a method
to his Madness but that tape job right there is
madness oh we all have our foibles don't we and
uh it's working for Tyler tuy tonight little
details and there aren't many guys that don't
have really anything at the top at all but one
little strip seems to agree with him in the first
five minutes big CH save and the rebound stopped
oh quick everybody going ooh and a to that one how
about those two saves the first one was excellent
the second one better and nobody can believe
this save what an unbelievable play by Jonathan
Quick I'm still wondering how you make his save
like that I don't know what are you asking me
for Shane gs's bear his shot to a screen Rebound
in the slot Soros moving around Far Side what a
save by Soros an absolute Masterpiece spred out on
the ice watch this save by Soros the Superman save
he's down and out Tangled with MCD and he jumps
across and catches it with the glove watch this he
has no business making this save oh my God Sabers
down 8 to four here as the puck right in front of
the Buffalo net singer drops it back scores now
nine to four back Doby there ooso scores they gave
up nine two nights ago they've got nine on the
board tonight kind of hard to believe isn't it
two nights later the difference in this building
now raning it again McKinnon a load scores 4
nothing Colorado and a shot in the goal and Loston
cruss get the coyotes on the board King again he
shoots he scores ohly 42 suer wrapper on he stores
and it's a one goal game Jersy towards the FR he
scores sh dersy he's tied it Jersey tried to give
it back he does save by goria BL pun score I can't
believe it wow you have got to be kidding me on
that play the ABS fall in overtime to the coyotes
5 to four I've seen everything now unbelievable
pack it comes for San on the score wow and it's
52 scores another one that's what you were saying
60 ft the shot he scores it's a one shot game now
popped off for L the Forester save made rebound
and they score it's a tie game trying to catch
up the shot primer looked behind him they score
it's 6 to5 Philadelphia all the way back from a
51 deficit that is one excited wrong can't sit
back and here we are clar scor from behind the
net it's 66 two and one in the game Patrick Kane
scar Brad Wings win it 7- six Patrick Kane what
a night coach shub with a save and an even bigger
save in they a shot from inside the blue line and
they'll score and The Islander Sebastian AO with
his first of the year makes it one- nothing now
stretch got in the bumper position but he gets
across they score Sebastian AO at the second
Sebastian AO to score in this still very young
hockey game we expected this was going to be
the case vasilki gave it up to domestic out back
to wiers he scores oh my a turnover by vasileski
ends up in the back of his own own net check to
the blue line by sud he'll just flip one each
door he bounced it PCH that was just a version of
a knuckle Puck as he flipped it bounced it over
the arm of the goal chender and it's 63 oh that
stinks for cor pelo this Maniac has been staring
you down and on bring the Bell stay away from me
don't hide by gret have you not seen gret SP my
muscle now stay away from me here today who we
set in tone and this is the reason he's ping the
price drop the hammer now the buck is dropped and
we are underway dumped in by the Stars on mono got
to make sure you hear the whistle as it's moved
outside of the Net score B 11 seconds in to the
new calendar year Dallas on the board courtesy of
their Captain and the guy we were just speaking of
maton had trouble with it behind the Nets toov
and his bid gets blocked in the trapezoid now
out in front score toov it fumbled off of colon
they did that last game 11 seconds in against
Montreal created a turnover this one just SLO out
of Ross Bon a yawning net for Guin toam yeah his
expression tells you on the bench he'll take it
Trails the play here's tan having a big Save By
doall The Rebound was in behind him D now knocked
it away what a stop he got a little piece of it
with the shaft of the stick and Jamie dryel comes
in twice prevents that puck from going over the
line boy oh boy Jamie D still with a real nice
play a scoring chance for the Jets they've had a
few there's one B SC Pinball Wizard one nothing
win a p this one plays Plinko on the way to the
net shot deflection off of a knee pad off of
a stick into the top Corner he'll take it the
front of the net they had a loose man there as
gooda was alone in front in how did that go in
ottawa's got the lead that's what about a foot
behind the goal line and Jones puts his glove
back thinking uhoh I felt that watch the shoulder
hits the shoulder rides up and it kind of rolls
right down his back and then finally drops down
got that to the neck go in front Robertson what
a stop by ketov and they'll have to look at this
that the glove that made the save cross the red
line Looks behind the line doesn't it logically
you'd say but do actually you need to see the
puck after the video review determined that the
puck did completely cross the goal line we have
a goal shoots in another sa Corpus Salo in front
chance kessing shoots another save and it goes
in it goes in and that goes off of hamic and into
the back of the net bar pasalo cannot believe it
get ready for Montreal and in front it scores and
Marchman that puck redirected it pinballed its way
and Marchman is going to close off that hatrick a
difficult one to pinpoint the ballistics on it you
had to go to the lab to figure this one out became
the six man for the Predators there aen loops it
in it's go it bounced off lar so Nashville gets
a thunderbolt out out of nowhere outside the Blue
Line he's trying to blocker this up and over into
the netting hits the inside of his blocker look
how hard he pushes overextends and deflects in the
back of the net this should never go in okay well
before you go I've been asked what is my Christmas
wish this year and I have said a Michigan or
LaCrosse or alleyoop or anything you'll give us
can you deliver Z I'm going to try I'm going to
try that's all I can do minakov brings it back
in drops it off to zis Trevor takes it in behind
the that he scores first on a cross goal exactly
what Allen lows off asked for Wow and that goes
wide now Bard again and he scores what a play he
hooked it in over his head I don't believe what I
just saw and it's one to one other worldly skill
here as he just softly picks that up on his stick
goes up over the shoulder to equalize this one at
one in comes aad plays it across for wheeler he is
back in Fr bouncy P SKS down they score a double
Hopper Finds Its way in and the Rangers have the
game's opening goal good luck trying to follow
that bouncing Puck Martin Jones had no idea where
it was I think Blake wheer might end up getting
it got for Pinsky left forer shoot score tipped
in first by wheeler Morgan riy get a piece of that
one Gord and I think that might be the second goal
in off a lead yep that's off Riley wow works it
back to G swings it across Panera and scores that
banked off of fo it was going 18 in wide of the
net this is the kind of night it's been for Martin
Jones who played really well yep logas logas SK
it's a piece and I guess you put enough fcks that
good things are going to happen a perfect December
in St Paul made even sweeter this afternoon Mark
Andre flurry getting the solo lap ahead of a huge
milestone set to play in career game 1,000 Toyota
intermission report sails on with the wild up
to I'm not sure what that beard is but it is
festive and it is that time of year caught on the
change F through Sams up and the rebound scores
and columus gets one back here's the initial shot
off his shoulder and just pops right down so it
is gon came through and look at that reaction of
samsonov that's one you got to have ball trying to
work away from Ryan McLoud turned over shot score
there's dry shidle hello and just like that MC
David and dry Sidle connect slow for Loco could
not redirect has it back in the net tried the
lacrosse style play and nearly beat flurry this
last look is the best one I think flurry makes the
save watch the the knob of a stick gets over there
covers the post top half of his stick that causes
the puck to redirect wide I think that bili has
lost his blade out of his skap he can't even move
he blocked that shot they're going to push him to
the bench give him a good shove there that's crazy
and finally was that like a mercy whistle poor
guy lton drags it off a stick connec me in tight
they score pinballs offin done their top goal
getter Travis ketne will pick up Philadelphia's
ninth short-handed goal the season four five now
it will come back up and Hutton will deliver this
one and it'll be deflected in it's the equipment
of I believe I believe it's in Brett pes's pants
it's in his heel the it's in his heel oh you heal
the heel job right here by pesy good stuff they're
getting in the lane by 22 bled in front and a long
gliding Puck for Jonathan Drew in and how about
Peter morazzi like the third defenseman look like
Dominic H coming out of the net like that great
play by morazzi assisting on the goal as well
just thuren give it up and they score just thurin
failed to clear the puck he had trouble gave
it away to Jordan Stall tell you what happened
Sam is that there was miscommunication between
Schneider and sturken as to who was going to make
the play with the puck that usually changes things
Watson scores Austin Watson throws it at the Nets
and it goes in and it's a tie G this is a bizarre
goal I'm guessing mono anticipated a touch but he
just throwing it at the net it's a bouncer and
he just playing misplays it look at the hit by
R forcing a turtle kulakov shoots sa mil K Chuck
on the rebounding score it's jamed home and the
Panthers add to the lead there's a rebound and
he just oh I think the defenseman is the one the
kessle ring popped it in but kachuck got it to the
blue paint into the middle now here's Wilson with
a shot Reb Sav by baseski it was Wilson who took
the initial shot and vasileski forced to make two
saves in succession there in conversation with the
great eight number 88 for Tampa yeah it was uh it
was awesome to see us get a start uh it's really
important you know moving having some Ben him and
uh and un y meeting his former teammate tal
Edon the head coach is to mcel look out the
capitalized handed the puck takes a bounce in
the corner and then pops right out it's going
over and it ends up hitting the stick up Schultz
and beats Joey to cord back to the blue paint
for cousins his shot blocker Sav s and it was
behind him and makoy behind the goenda it out
of the air that was on its way in and that is
a beauty on the backand no l and then he slides
into the net and watch this Jan he still tries
to not make contact with swayan that's smooth
that is really smooth Jeremy San showing
a little love for Charlie maoy for helping
out his stats a little bit extra attacker
it's on the stick of fetch nikov takes in
for the hattick bigo here come the hats by the
way the state fair is what about a th000 yards
from us Andre sikov might have just invented a
new game at the state fair that was a [Music]
bullseye